la vie semble continuer normalement pour
emilie dubois une jeune graphiste
scientifique travailleuses autonomes à
québec
pourtant au printemps dernier sa vie a
basculé en ouvrant une lettre du
ministère de l'immigration
on refusait de lui donner un certificat
de sélection du québec
c'est comme une avalanche qui tombe sur
la tête puis en sais pas pourquoi elle
n'est pas justifiée
puis moi je me suis sentie rejetée
française d'origine diplômés du doctorat
à l'université laval en biologie
cellulaire et moléculaire
elle a complété sa thèse à l'hiver 2010
8 mai elle a rédigé un de ses chapitres
en anglais une vingtaine de pages fatale
le ministère a jugé qu'elle n'avait pas
entièrement complété son programme en
français et c'est la surprise parce que
tous les étudiants en sciences
communique en anglais ça fait partie des
habitudes pour corriger le tir la jeune
femme de 31 ans a demandé un délai elle
a passé un test de connaissance du
français puis a envoyé ses résultats au
ministère en vain ma ville et là on ne
peut pas me dire que que je prouve que
je crois pas que tu en français et que
je dois rentrer en france
c'est sûr que c'est net à prétention qui
extrême masse très boisée de la part du
fonctionnaire en question malgré
l'étrangeté de la situation cet avocat
ne crois pas que le ministère a commis
une erreur de droit administratif le cas
d'emilie dubois illustrent cependant les
limites du programme de l'expérience
québécoise notamment qu'il n'est pas
accessible aux travailleurs autonomes
ça veut dire que les gens qui viennent
ici pour ouvrir des entreprises faire
des affaires au québec on vraiment pas
beaucoup d'options de risque dans ce cas
là on a une fille française s'appelle
emilie dubois qui est refusé à cause
qu'on n'a pas de preuves de sa
connaissance français la députée de
taschereau promec ce dossier n'en
restera pas là
si on n'a pas pris son corps avec
intelligence dans les dédales
administratif nous notre job c'est de
faire la lumière là dessus je suis à
l'écouté des gens et j'ai réfléchi
la clause de droit acquis annoncées
mercredi par le gouvernement représente
une lueur d'espoir pour emilie dubois
même si elle pourra sans doute faire une
nouvelle demande elle avait ce message a
lancé on n'est pas des numéros on est
vraiment des personnes puis par rapport
aux on est en plein emploi mais laissait
aussi la place à des créations nouveaux
emplois je pourrais en être un exemple
s'il faut le ministère de l'immigration
n'a pas répondu à nos questions
ici alexandre duval radio canada québec